benoît martin merci d'accepter de
répondre à nos questions alors le chef
de l'état s'est donc entretenu on lisait
avec les partenaires sociaux ce matin
sur les difficultés rencontrées par les
salariés quelle inquiétude pour les
salariés ont partagé les syndicats avec
le président de la république mais en
fait la délégation cgt a surtout
présenté ce qui était déjà dans le
contenu dans la lettre ouverte qui avait
été adressée au président de la
république par philippe martinez mardi
dernier donc le 7 avril
et donc voilà on en a déjà on est parti
de cette contradiction fondamentale qui
perdure depuis déjà 24 jours 7
qu'en dire cette demande qui est fait à
la fois de rester confinés et d'aller
travailler et donc pour nous la société
premier coin c'est qu'il ya de trop de
gens sur leur lieu habituel de travail
aujourd'hui en france ah ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point qui a
été pointée par la délégation cgt
c'est là le recul du droit du travail
que l'on conteste ce n'est pas parce
qu'il ya une crise sanitaire qu'il faut
allonger la durée du travail est enlevée
d imposer en tout cas des jours de
congés payés aux salariés et puis on a
parlé également un petit peu du jour
d'après eux
voilà comment envoyer là en quoi cette
société française mêmes questions
planétaires également comment les
sociétés humaines seraient modifiés
après cette crise extrêmement forte
alors pour vous les mesures de
protection à proposer sur les lieux de
travail ce n'est pas suffisant pour les
salariés alors ce n'est pas suffisant on
a des remontées de terrain qui nous font
intervenir auprès des employeurs parfois
en associant les inspections du travail
la direction régionale de l'emploi et du
travail également
parfois en faisant intervenir la
préfecture et quand ce n'est pas
suffisant on fait également des
communiqués de presse en utilisent
effectivement l'euro
et médiatique pour faire connaître des
situations et il arrive même que la cgt
ou d'autres organisations syndicales et
bien déposé des plaintes auprès des
juridictions compétentes également alors
qu'est ce que vous demandez très
concrètement pour permettre aux salariés
de traverser cette crise le plus
sereinement possible
eh bien on veut que ce soit au travail
sans vendu le travail habituel que les
salariés qui ont un rôle fondamental
dans fonctionnement de l'assemblée la
société que ce soit le médical bien
entendu que ce soit la protection ad des
citoyens que ce soit le fait de nourrir
les citoyens et puis il aimait les
services publics fondamentaux tels que
fournir de de l'eau potable ramasser les
poubelles etc etc
gardez également les enfants des gens
que je viens de mentionner que ce soit
dans les écoles les crèches ou les
centres de loisirs notamment en ce
moment en cette période de congés
scolaires dans la zone c est donc qu on
veut que les autres gens soient chez eux
confiné 1 pour ne pas répandre cette
virus ne pas être vecteur de la pandémie
et puis pour soulager les l'hôpital
public également donc il ya du
télétravail c'est une logique et
d'ailleurs les télétravailleurs ne sont
pas sans droit non plus mais il ya aussi
à 6 millions de de chômage parce de gens
qui sont au chômage partiel aujourd'hui
ça pourrait être au delà
par exemple aujourd'hui à des gens qui
travaillent dans le dtp qui sont sur des
chantiers de construction qui n'ont
aucun caractère d'urgence et pour nous
ces gens là sont exposés à des dangers
et c'est extrêmement grave
mais justement sur cette question du
chômage partiel notamment avec toutes
ces dépenses à engager par le
gouvernement est ce que vous ne craignez
pas que les salariés seront appelés à
prêts à faire davantage d'efforts
justement alors la santé d'abord la
fille sauver des vies d'abord ensuite il
faudra effectivement relancer la machine
économique il y aura une quantité de
travail importante mais cherche souvent
sans en un
voilà il ne va pas avoir une croissance
positive cette année on sait bien un peu
partout dans le monde il n'y aura pas
que la france donc une récession mais
écoutez il va falloir de toute manière
après un départ d'un plan de relance
économique du financement du travail de
l'emploi pour faire repartir la machine
mais en ce moment ce n'est pas le sujet
principal en ce moment c'est de sauver
des vies de soulager le personnel
hospitalier et puis aussi de enfin moi
je suis quand même assez choqué que l'on
découvre comme ça avec beaucoup de
retard le les chiffres de de mordre dans
les ehpad
pour moi il de enfin pour la cgt il
devrait y avoir un tableau de bord
sanitaires concernant les ehpad et
concernant de la santé en général
qu'ils soient établis en permanence
n'est pas seulement essayé de le
construire en ce moment en rattrapage au
moment d'une crise
alors on le voit c'est le personnel
hospitalier qui est en première ligne
sur le front un depuis début de cette
pandémie quelle est votre regard là
encore sur la gestion du gouvernement
par rapport à ce personnel et bien il y
a des des manquements notés très
nettement un donc la pandémie est là
donc la capacité d'accueil dans les
hôpitaux a été augmentée il a fallu
faire un peu d quasiment des miracles
pour pousser les murs comme j'ai entendu
l'expression mais ceci dit ce n'est pas
tout alors il ya aussi du personnel de
santé qui est qui se proposait
volontaires pour renforcer les équipes
d'autres ont été réquisitionnés c'est
assez logique mais il manque du matériel
à un manque d 10 / blues il manque en
tous genres ces fameux basque et il
manque aussi dans les hôpitaux
parfois d'une cure et d'autres
médicaments acquis seront nécessaires
pour les hospitalisations lourde mais
pour la réanimation
donc voilà il ya un système de pénurie 1
donc la france le système français de
santé n'a pas été préparée à répondre à
cet événement qui est certainement
relativement rare mais qui était malgré
tout prévisible c'est logique que
parfois dans la vie il ya des des crises
des événements inattendus certains des
catastrophes naturelles des catastrophes
industrielles mais aussi des épidémies
merci beaucoup benoît martin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire de l'union
départementale de la cgt paris